le groupe airwell spécialisé dans les
solutions de climatisation et de
chauffage vient de lancer son deuxième
centre de formation à 50 ans en Yvelines
à Montigny-le-Bretonneux plus
précisément ce dernier est dédié à la
filière du génie climatique donc tout ce
qui traite au chauffage à la
climatisation et à la ventilation au
total 3 formations pour en parler avec
nous Laurent Rogel je le rappelle vous
êtes le CO du groupe airwell alors quels
sont ces trois formations qui sont
proposées par la airway Academy alors on
est sur des formations alors à l'origine
comme je vous le disais on a créé ce
erwall Academy pour répondre aux besoins
de la filière donc on était beaucoup
plus sur des formations métier pour leur
apprendre les rudiments du métier
comment bien installer des pompes à
chaleur parce que 90% des problèmes en
général viennent de problèmes
d'installation donc bien installé suivre
les règles de l'art etc après on est
arrivé sur une phase beaucoup plus
certification qualification
pour pour travailler sur nos métiers par
de la même manière l'État a mis en place
à juste titre énormément de
certification de régulation pour
s'assurer que les formateurs
les bonnes les bonnes compétences donc
des Cali packs des Cali PV on appelle ça
des label RGE etc
reconnu garant l'environnement etc donc
toute cette partie certification était
nécessaire et la troisième le troisième
niveau le troisième étage on va dire
c'était pour répondre à ce besoin de ce
besoin de force vive que nos métiers
rencontrent alors pas que nos métiers
mais les nôtres qui connaissent une très
très grosse croissance sur des
supermarchés qui croient de 20 à 30% par
an donc ça nécessitait énormément de
main d'oeuvre et de et de qualité donc
la plupart de nos acteurs de nos
partenaires installateurs
seront se trouver vraiment en difficulté
pour recruter pour recruter des
personnes qualifiées donc on est en
cours de construction et c'est un peu le
but de ce deuxième centre de formation
ici qui va aussi faire les formations
certifiantes et qualifiantes mais qui va
se développer sur la partie insertion
donc qui va travailler avec avec les
organismes de public pour créer des
formations diplômantes permettant de
Greta permettant de proposer des des
installateurs alors c'est des formations
qui peuvent les trois mois à 18 mois en
fonction de la qualité ou la pétanque
technique ou de niveau de certification
du stagiaire on adapte la formation à au
personnel pour qu'ils puissent au bout
de cette période trouver un emploi soit
chez nous parce qu'on a évidemment des
besoins soit auprès de notre réseau de
nos réseaux installateurs et
distributeurs qui eux ont des besoins
significatifs sur la région de
Saint-Quentin mais aussi sur le Bassin
parisien et donc vous en avez un peu
parlé mais quel est l'objectif de ces
trois formations c'est permettre une
meilleure insertion vers l'emploi c'est
un peu multiple disons on a lancé une
démarche alors qu'on appelle RSE sur
leur donner un nom il y a quelques
années autour de la responsabilité
sociale sociétale et environnementale de
l'entreprise on estime qu'une entreprise
a avant tout une raison sociale pas
forcément qu'une raison financière donc
à ce titre on a développé tout un
organisme toute une organisation avec
des indicateurs un peu différents que
simplement régner de l'argent sur le
développement de notre bassin
territorial de la société autour de nous
et d'apporter cette touche
environnementale aussi donc quand vous
faites l'ensemble de ces la jonctions
avec ces trois ces trois ambitions on va
dire
on s'est rapproché aussi de la BPI la
banque publique d'investissement donc on
est ce qu'on appelle coq vert donc ça
fait c'est la communauté de toutes les
entreprises qui touchent la transition
énergétique et environ 1000 entreprises
en France mais donc vous faites le lien
entre la transition énergétique et
l'insertion finalement parce que c'est
extrêmement important d'apporter cette
offre d'insertion sur des métiers
d'avenir tant qu'à faire c'est quand
même plus simple de former des personnes
et de les réinsérer sur des métiers qui
vont durer plusieurs dizaines d'années
et qui sont rémunérateurs donc le
l'alignement des étoiles s'est fait
relativement facilement autour de cette
de cette ambition et donc justement qui
s'adresse ces formations
des scolarisé au seniors en recherche
d'emploi depuis de nombreuses années au
réfugiés à toutes les personnes sur les
toutes les populations qui ont besoin
d'être insérées qui ne sont pas
forcément dans les parcours habituels
type Pôle emploi parce que cela
finalement
l'État ou les organisations les suivre
relativement bien on est sur un niveau
de quasi pleine emploi même largement
plein emploi sur nos métiers donc on
doit chercher on doit sourcer comme on
le disait tout à l'heure on doit sourcer
des personnes qui ne sont pas dans les
radars habituels de ce qu'une entreprise
comme la nôtre a l'habitude ou nos
clients ont l'habitude de trouver donc
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin le
secteur du génie climatique se porte
bien sur le territoire de 50 ans je
pense que si il suffit d'écouter les
médias à peu près tous les jours pour se
rendre compte de l'importance de de la
rénovation énergétique en général du
fait que la pompe à chaleur soit la
seule solution qui soit validée par
l'Europe et donc par la France pour la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
que donc les installateurs et les
mainteneurs ont un travail devant eux
considérable le problème de ces
installateurs n'est pas leur carnet de
commandes et de savoir comment ils vont
trouver les employés pour réaliser ce
carnet de commandes donc on est là aussi
en dehors de la en dehors de leur
proposer des solutions innovantes et des
produits on est là aussi pour leur
proposer des solutions de recrutement
avec des personnes qualifiées alors
comment on fait pour revenir à ces
formations alors on a inauguré le centre
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la semaine
dernière donc c'est tout les panneaux
sont encore fraîches donc on a un site
un roi académie.com ou sur le site
airwell.com le site général du groupe on
trouve forcément les liens ou sur
internet évidemment
après on rentre dans un parcours
qualifié on va dire qualifiant on
vérifie quand même l'expertise le
l'historique le comportement de chaque
de chaque de chaque personne parce qu'on
est sur des populations très différentes
très diverses on parle on intègre pas du
tout la main de la même manière une
personne réfugiée qu'un jeune
déscolarisé ou qu'un seniors on est sur
des sur des prérequis on va dire sur le
le comportemental de plus en plus
beaucoup plus important que sur des
formations métier que nous on avait
l'habitude de dispenser donc il y a il y
a un peu de travail en amont qui a
réalisé par des spécialistes chez nous
qui ont l'habitude de ce genre de de
population et et dès lors qu'on a passé
cette période là après on rentre dans
une dans une période qui s'adapte comme
je vous disais de trois mois à 18 mois
en fonction de la compétence technique
ou du de l'historique de la personne
et bien merci beaucoup Laurent d'avoir
répondu à nos questions si vous êtes
intéressé par les formations dispensées
par la airwell académie vous trouverez
donc plus d'informations sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran allez c'est l'heure maintenant
d'ouvrir une page de sport dans votre 7